este camión lleno de personas acabo de
llegar de etiopía lleva a 10 personas
que dejaron todo cuando el conflicto
empezó al otro lado de la frontera estos
hombres estaban en el campo cuando
escucharon el primer disparo y huyeron
pasamos tres días en la carretera
llevaban seis u ocho días desde que dejé
mi casa y desde entonces he vivido
afuera la gente huye a donde puede no
hay nadie en los pueblos mira mi ropa no
tengo nada que comer ni tomar no me
queda nada la gente fue asesinada vemos
cadáveres en todas partes sin ser
enterrados ellos están armados
monitoreando todo así que no podemos
enterrar a la gente estábamos muy
asustados por nuestras vidas así que
vivimos unos kilómetros más adelante
llegan a la primera población sudanesa
muchas casas están vacías aquí y algunas
familias pudieron encontrar refugio sin
embargo miles no tienen techo y la ayuda
no ha llegado aún mira esta casa no hay
nada adentro y mira estos niños no han
comido en al menos cinco días como los
vamos a alimentar nosotros vivimos para
salvar a nuestros niños vinimos aquí han
pasado cinco días llegamos a pie desde
el pueblo my cadera el ejército de sudán
nos trajo
desde la frontera gracias a dios nos
trajeron aquí pero dónde está la comida
dónde podemos tomar agua los niños se
están muriendo la agencia de refugiados
de las naciones unidas indicó que
trasladaría a estas familias etíopes a
una nueva locación que tendría que ser
construida al menos 11.000 personas ya
están allí y los refugiados siguen
llegando un más viejo luego estamos
registrando un promedio de 400 a 500
personas que llegan cada 12 horas hoy
desde las 5 de la mañana hasta la una de
la tarde hemos reportado 500 refugiados
el gobierno de sudán distribuyó comida y
ropa pero no fue suficiente los
comerciantes venden los elementos de
necesidades básicas a los migrantes sin
embargo sólo unos pocos pueden
comprarlos y siguen esperando la ayuda
internacional para poder sobrevivir